Так виглядає особливий шлях Швеції:
люди вільно спілкуються на терасах ресторанів.
Звичайне життя, яке неможливо побачити
у багатьох країнах світу.
Під час пандемії коронавірусу Швеція відмовилась
від суворих заходів ізоляції та зробила ставку
на свідомість своїх громадян,
які мають дотримуватися рекомендацій влади.
Тут по-іншому влаштоване суспільство,
і тут люди справді слідують урядовим рекомендаціям.
І якщо ми подивимося на дані, які було оприлюднено
кілька тижнів тому, коли був Великдень,
то дані стільникових операторів показують, що шведи
на 90-95 відсотків
скоротили пересування всередині країни
у Великодній період,
у той період, коли зазвичай
усі подорожують країною.
Тобто, аби цього досягти,
не потрібно було забороняти
людям виїздити з міст.
Але й шведи не завжди виявляють свідомість.
Кількість людей на вулиці сильно залежить від погоди.
Шведів дуже важко умовити залишатись вдома,
коли сяє сонце і стає тепло.
І коли було три теплих дні, людей було помітно більше.
Влада країни застерігає, що недотримання рекомендацій
може загрожувати запровадженням
більш суворих заходів ізоляції.
Дозвольте мені внести максимальну ясність.
Я не хочу бачити переповнені тераси ресторанів
ані у Стокгольмі, ані деінде.
Кожен має нести за це відповідальність.
Тепер усе залежить від кожного з нас:
чи будуть запроваджені суворіші заходи чи ні,
чи буде закрито ресторани чи ні.
Кілька пабів у Стокгольмі зачинили, оскільки ті не виконали
вимоги Агентства охорони громадського здоров'я Швеції.
Рівень довіри шведів до цієї незалежної від влади установи
під час пандемії лише виріс.
До 74 відсотків, згідно
з опитуваннями у березні.
Однак стратегією, яку обрала ця служба,
задоволені далеко не всі:
періодично у відкритих листах вчені та лікарі
вимагають запровадити
повноцінні карантинні заходи.
Ми не знаємо напевно, як багато людей вже заразилися коронавірусом.
Каже професорка Каролінгського інституту.
Скільки з них дітей, в яких
немає симптомів,
але симптоми з'являються в батьків.
Усе це абсолютно незрозуміло.
Звичайно, можна вирішити: стан справ незрозумілий,
тому ми відправимо дітей до шкіл,
а можна вирішити –
стан справ незрозумілий,
тому ми не відправимо дітей до шкіл.
Агенція охорони громадського здоров'я
вже визнала низку помилок.
Не вдалося запобігти спалаху коронавірусу
в будинках літніх людей.
Було відкликано дослідження
з некоректними даними.
У Швеції зареєстровано більше 2200 випадків
смерті від коронавірусу.
При цьому в Агентстві не приховують,
що доповнюють статистику
померлих від коронавірусу заднім числом,
коли знаходять ці випадки.
Політики, тим не менше, захищають
обрану країною лінію.
Ми не чекаємо того моменту,
коли буде ще більше смертей.
Ми робимо усе можливе,
аби виконувати ті правила,
які ми встановили, тримати дистанцію, перевіряти,
що люди не збираються у великі групи,
що ті, хто може залишитися вдома, залишаються вдома,
що люди дотримуються
заходів особистої гігієни тощо.
Ми робимо усе, що в наших силах,
і взагалі не кажемо
про жодне послаблення обмежень.
Ми кажемо про посилення обмежень.
Поки ж влада країни, які і раніше, робить ставку
на здоровий глузд населення
й м'які заходи боротьби з коронавірусом.